hello and welcome to the spectators
alternative
conference our latest event is the
pathway to net zero
how has kobit 19 impacted the uk's
pledge to reduce carbon emissions
uh this has been very kindly sponsored
by scottish power
and we have we might not be in
birmingham but we do have an
absolutely fantastic panel where for you
to discuss this
question with we have quasi quasing who
is
the minister of state at the department
of business uh
energy and industrial strategy and is in
charge of clean growth fair
we have baroness brown of cambridge he's
the vice chair of the uk committee on
climate change
and chair of the carbon trust we have
james diggle who's head of energy and
climate change at the
cbi and keith anderson who's the chief
executive
officer for scottish power now one of
the
uh effects of kovan 19 is that it
massively reduced
the uk's carbon emissions during the
lockdown but
that cut is obviously only a temporary
measure
and uh the uk along alongside nearly
every other country is not currently on
course to hit
net zero by 2050 but the uk
is hosting next year uh cop 26 in
glasgow and this is going to one of the
major diplomatic events for post-brexit
britain
and the question comes whether the uk
can show that it is
going to um lead the way in global terms
in getting to net zero
and how to do that is the question we're
going to be discussing today
so what i'm going to do is and ask all
the speakers to speak for two minutes or
so a couple of minutes at the beginning
and then we'll throw but we'll have some
panel discussion and we'll throw it open
to your questions
um quasi i was wondering if you wanted
to start us off with a few minutes on
what the government is doing to net zero
and how it's going to get there
we're doing a great deal and i just i
just want to say uh
that we should really remember where
we've come from
um as far as decarbonization is
concerned that's something that's been
going on
uh for more than 30 years now
if you look at where we were in 1990 and
look at where we are now
we've managed to grow the economy by 75
percent
while reducing carbon emissions by 43
so it is possible to decarbonize an
economy and grow it at the same time and
that's
really at the center of what we're
trying to do in terms of specifics that
we're doing ahead of cop26
uh we've got an energy white paper
coming out which i know the industry is
eagerly awaiting
we've got a hydrogen strategy which will
i think be
a world-leading uh document in terms of
how we can
harness hydrogen uh for a greener
economy
we've got we're looking at heat and
buildings and how we can improve
uh the installation of uh buildings and
as
well as decarbonizing uh heat sources
through heat pumps and possibly also
through the use of hydrogen
uh in the future in in the grid system
um
we are committed we've already committed
i think three billion pounds
uh this summer to uh various schemes
which will decarbonize
uh buildings the green homes grant is
two billion pounds which is being rolled
out this month
so there are a whole range of things
that we're doing uh across a range of
technologies
um which i think will help us uh
power our way to net zero now there's
still a lot more uh
to be done and as you've said um we're
slightly off the
uh carbon budget period four and more
considerably of five
uh so there's more work to be done but
uh i think there's plenty
to be getting on with and we are
definitely um rolling out policies that
will help us get there
uh baroness brown what grade would you
give the government's efforts to hit
net zero by 2050 um i think
um quasi has has already said
that yes you know we're hearing the
right noises
some of the right announcements have
been made but we really have to get on
and do it
and accelerate the pace and i think
it's it's good to reflect um as we think
about
what we're going to do um to to build
our way out of
out of the um covid crisis
it's it's good to reflect on for example
the success of
of renewable energy spending i mean if
you look at the ersted share price
compared to the bp share price
trajectory even before the pandemic
um ersted were shooting up and bp had
had flattened off um global renewable
energy spending is set to
surpass oil and gas in 2021 i think once
we get there
there's really going to be an amazing
acceleration
and it creates three times as many jobs
per pound spent um in renewables as we
do in fossil fuels
so that really says that's the kind of
thing that it's going to be very
important for us to be doing
um more of and as quasi is flagged up
the the key areas
in the uk for immediate investment which
can support jobs and
leveling up are exactly things like the
building retrofit that he has
talked about the energy efficiency the
low carbon heat
and the adapting to homes for the high
temperatures we're going to see
in the summer but also we could be
accelerating our
our flood protection program we could be
accelerating our nature-based solutions
program with tree planting and nature
restoration
we could be accelerating our low carbon
vehicle infrastructure
these are all things we can get onto
very quickly create jobs
all over the place and will really help
with the uh
the leveling up agenda and i think as
quasi has touched on too
so i'm you know very much in line with
him but just i think want him
to be able to move even faster um there
are really key areas for net zero
which are also key areas for the uk's
competitive future
and which bill really build on our
strengths so renewable energy like
offshore wind
but as quasi has mentioned hydrogen
which really draws on
capabilities and and companies already
in the uk with
fantastic opportunities for growth and
and carbon capture and storage and
things like that
so you know i think we're we're well
positioned i think
we do really need to see the government
take the opportunity of
um the opportunity of low interest rates
uh and
indeed the the interest of international
investors
to help us drive these things really
really rapidly now
thank you so much for having us bran
keith anderson you're the ceo of a power
company
from the perspective of industry how do
you think things are going how well do
you think the uk is handling
all of this well i i think there's a
a brilliant opportunity so i think the
great thing is that
um you know what we're hearing from lots
of stakeholders
uh politicians from the government from
everyone it just
seems to be a really good general
agreement that
uh a great source of economic recovery
is to do as a green recovery and
therefore an awful lot of the focus on
life now about
not just about should we do 2050 is 2050
difficult
you know most of the conversation now is
about how can we accelerate how can we
do more how can we do it faster
and i think the great thing is is
bringing together lots of good positive
elements
where most people accept a great way to
do an economic recovery in the back of a
crisis is through investment
through investment and infrastructure
because it's big
investment infrastructure tends to be
labor intensive so you create the jobs
you create training opportunities
apprenticeship opportunities
and then if you make that infrastructure
related to
greening and decarbonizing so whether
that's in the
the energy infrastructure the
transmission system the distribution
system
whether it's directly in the
decarbonization of transport or the
heating system
etc what you're doing is you're taking
all the right boxes you're accelerating
2050
you're creating jobs you're creating
supply chain contracts
you're creating manufacturing and you're
creating an economic recovery
and you're you're getting yourself to
2050 so lots of
great things lined up i suppose that
you're from a business point of view
um we then want to translate that into
hard-nosed practical steps
so we issued our 10-point practical step
plan
as to how you do this in and around
areas like acceleration of renewables
offshore wind solar onshore wind
acceleration of transport investment
uh so the rollout of ev infrastructure
and then the creation of a heat market
and the rollout of heat
because our view is all of those things
will create jobs very very quickly
all of those things will create supply
chain contracts and lots and lots of
investment very very very quickly so
those are the things we would like to
see being triggered pretty much
immediately
and and they can go now the other great
thing is they're all existing
technologies we're not trying to invent
something new to do that and to deliver
it
and that's where we came up with that
came up with the kind of simple
methodology of
you know use the next 10 to 15 years and
electrify the hell out of everything
with your existing technology
and use that to buy you the time to go
and test and prove what we can and can't
do with hydrogen
how hydrogen can help where hydrogen
where hydrogen can help
look at technologies like ccs and other
things as well
because we'll need all of those tools in
the box at the latest stage
but don't slo don't slow down don't wait
push ahead and deliver it now and you'll
you'll get yourself on that path to 2050
and you'll create jobs in the meantime
brilliant as well that we've got cop26
coming to the uk
coming to glasgow next year that gives
us a really really good boost
to focus attention and to focus delivery
in and around that cot coming so we can
show what steps we've made
we can demonstrate the innovation in the
uk we can demonstrate the new technology
in the uk
and we can show the rest of the world
here's how you do this
here's how you drive this and the last
thing i'll say is speed
the faster we go the better because
every country in the world is going to
look to do exactly what we're looking to
do
they'll all be chasing the same money
the same capital the same technology the
same innovation
so the faster we move the better it is
for the country
the better it is for the economy and the
better it is for the future
that's me brilliant thank you so much
keith um
james from the perspective of uh
business more broadly um is there a you
know how comfortable are firms with the
with trying to with the changes that we
necessary if we are going to get to net
zero by
2050 you know i think you know the
the interesting thing with the net zero
target is from the perspective of the
cbi
how sort of broadly it's been been taken
on board and actually how
you know when we look across sectors
it's really triggering a new type of
thinking you know whether it's you know
the energy sector we just heard about
but
across all different uh types of firms
across the economy you know people are
sort of stepping up to
this challenge and you know the the
development of corporate net zero
targets and
every week you know we seem to see you
know a new set of targets set
um you know and and that's hugely
exciting so i think that that that
buy-in is there
you know obviously the pandemic is is
still causing
huge issues and and and some parts of
the economy are hit harder
uh than others so i think you know we
always have to think about how
how we could have get through the you
know the upcoming weeks and months and
and that's still the kind of the
the time horizon that many businesses
are looking at
but i don't think it's dampening the
expectations about what we need to
achieve on the climate
um and you know we've heard about you
know all the all the things coming up
from from government which you know
which are exciting but there you know
it's clearly
a moment to pivot it's a it's a moment
to change to something better you know
we have this opportunity we
have the deadline of cop 26 as well um
and i think you know
from my position i hear so many of our
of our members again from across sectors
saying what does
what does cop26 mean and what can we do
to take part you know how can we do our
bit to deliver
emissions reduction so even though know
we're still going through
um the depths of a crisis you know the
the longer term vision of what we need
to achieve i think is israel is really
there and you know it's
it's why across the last few months the
cbi has
written two policy papers and done a
conference already on on the on the idea
of the green recovery and the need to
get net zero so that business backing is
really there
james thank you so much um quasi if i
may
uh when you look at this the obvious
political question
right now is the government is going to
embrace the kind of green keynesianism
which you can see as a kind of popular
uh response kind of economic growth
driving response to this pandemic and
the recession and the economic damage
that it's bound to follow
but i think the more difficult issue is
it not is when it comes down to trying
to change consumer behavior in ways that
people aren't necessarily happy with for
example you know
no more um hybrids or petrol or diesel
cars to be sold after 2030.
um you represent a kind of suburban
southern english constituency
how much public appetite do you think
there is for the changes that will be
necessary to give this contingency
when i was first elected in 2010 i can
assure you about that
um and i was noting that um last
uh december was the fifth general
election in which i've been a candidate
so over 15 years
i've been a general uh election
candidate in five of those elections
and this was the first time in 2019 that
the issue of
global warming of climate change of
carbon reductions
actually came up on the doorstep i mean
not all the time
but it was spontaneously referred to in
a way that i can't remember it
uh having been referred to before so i
think that's a huge
step in the right direction it was
interesting in your question you
mentioned the fact that we're going to
push forward uh the um the rollout of
evs or the
um withdrawal of uh petrol and diesel
cars
and that actually answers your question
the fact that we can move this forward
suggests that there is actually more
appetite than we anticipated at the
beginning
only a year ago or 18 months ago we were
talking about 2040
and now we're talking about 2035 2032
people are even suggesting
20 30. so the fact that that number
rather that year
that date has been brought forward as
quickly as it has been
suggests to me that there is actually a
lot more appetite out there for the kind
of changes
that you've described now that doesn't
mean that we still don't have a problem
in terms of bringing larger numbers over
uh
and persuading them but i think that the
the the current has definitely the
currents have definitely shifted
over the last five or ten years and i
think this is something which
all the major parties um are are
agreeing about nobody's saying
oh this is going to be too fast uh we
are not carrying people with us
uh you know nobody nobody's saying that
uh baroness brown do you think there is
a case um after brexit for the uk to
introduce its own carbon tax
um well of course we we effectively do
have quite a few
embedded carbon taxes already but i i
i i i've never quite understood why
governments weren't more enthusiastic
about carbon
taxes you know a new way to to raise
revenue and also to do good at the same
time and and i
i know i'd i'd actually like to see us
thinking about bringing a carbon tax
back on fuel because i think it would
help
um move us towards people understanding
the lower costs of uh
running uh buying and running electric
vehicles
so i think it would be very good to be
seeing a much stronger debate about a uk
carbon tax yes
quasi are you up for a carbon tax are
you a pygovian
well no i'm not i'm not a big carbon tax
fan
i mean i think it has its uses and
merits but on balance i'd much rather
have
uh ets which is or the uk uh ets which
is an emission
uh uh emission um transaction
sort of credit uh system so and
the benefit of that is it actually
limits the amount of emissions
that you can have in the system whereas
all the carbon tax does is
disincentivize
uh bad behavior now if people want to
uh make carbon all they have to do is
pay attacks and they can do so
merrily and i don't think the carbon tax
is necessarily the best instrument
if your you know sole purpose is to
reduce
or your principal purpose is to reduce
the actual level of
carbon emissions uh keith you talked
about i'm
kind of electrifying the hell out of
everything while you looked into kind of
other alternative solutions such as
hydrogen
um on on that point one thing you hear
from people which is
you know with the electricity network as
you get out into kind of rural britain
you know isn't powerful enough to to to
quickly
to to charge electric vehicles fast
enough do you think that's a valid
criticism
oh look so we you know i think john this
relates to the previous question as well
the
this answer which is look the the trick
to doing all of this
and and to carry creating this
conversion and
engaging people is we need to make this
really really easy for people
and we need to make it really really
obvious so that when somebody walks
through
or gets to the decision point or walks
through the door whether it's for a car
or a new heating system that actually
we're not having to at that point time
convince them
about the merits of an electric car but
that point in time
actually why wouldn't you buy an
electric car
yeah so we need to make it that simple
that's straightforward and that obvious
and the same with heating
that actually people will think you know
what the obvious choice is an electric
heat pump
okay so we need to therefore drive down
the cost
um get the innovation coming through so
these choices become
obvious simple easy choices for people
to make
as and when the time to switch these
products and these processes
and it's the same for industrial
processes so you know this whole idea
about hydrogen
to me is i i think you know isn't so
much about your
your um public cars or public transport
you know this is about you know big
industrial processes and maybe a big
industrial machinery and big industrial
vehicles
um and again we need to get to use the
time
to push that hydrogen invest in it in
its early stage
then look how the innovation can drive
down the cost and we can take it to
market
and again therefore it becomes easier
and simpler for businesses to make that
switch
so when they're looking at the
reinvestment and the manufacturing and
production processes
your if it's high energy and the right
answer or if it's electricity
that what we then do is we're making
easy simple and obvious folk to make the
switch
and that's really where you need to get
to you know it was
it's you know that's been the great
success of offshore renewables as it's
been the obvious choice
we created the right market we created
the right framework
we got the right level of innovation we
drove down the cost
and now everybody knows offshore winds
cheap okay
and we need to do the same on transport
we need to do the same with heat
we need to do the same with industrial
processes that we get to this point
where actually
it's cost competitive and therefore
there's no the barriers start getting
removed
now that's a two-state some of that for
for market ready technology
create the right framework and it will
come through for technology that's not
market ready
that's where we need the government to
sit and help as well and we look at how
do we get the right investment and the
prototypes
how do we get the r d through how do we
get it to a point where we can get it to
be market ready and we can flip it into
a market mechanism
that way you avoid having to rely on
huge amounts of government
spending and government support you
deliver it through private capital and
private investment
a mixture of good regulatory frameworks
and good market frameworks
like the real framework for networks and
distribution
and like the cfd framework for
renewables that drives the investment
so yes the the background infrastructure
is critical the worst thing in the world
you can do
is infuse such as drive down the cost of
an electric car
and fuse somebody to to want to buy an
electric car
and then they get told they can't charge
it so we need to make sure the
background infrastructure is constantly
being invested
so that doesn't become a barrier and it
doesn't become a blockage
and so the faster we do that as well the
better other great thing about doing
that
if you invest like hell in that
infrastructure now you will create jobs
you'll create supply chain contracts
you'll complete com
and trigger an economic recovery so we
should push ahead with it yeah
james from a business point of view do
you think business has the certainty
that it needs to make these
investment decisions um you know for
example i think if you were a business
that had moved to a kind of hybrid fleet
of cars
you might be rather irritated to find
the government suddenly changing its
position on
hybrid vehicles you know you had gordon
brown encouraging people to move to
diesel only for diesel now to be
regarded as a problem rather than a
solution
um do you think there is the business
have a confidence in
in governments of all stripes really to
make these long-term decisions
yeah i mean you you identify a really
important point which is the need for
that that certainty because you know the
investment cycles that business work on
a multi-year
they go beyond governments and
parliaments and you know we we need that
that certainty and yeah we want to come
back to the
the question around you know how do we
make the uk the best place
to to invest i think you know the you
know the you know leaving the eu
as well it gives us a moment to think
about that again you know what what is
going to be you know that the uk is kind
of selling point so i think really kind
of
long-term thinking in our policy
frameworks and our regulatory frameworks
as well as
uh as keith mentioned there so i think
it's it's really important you know i
think um
you know we've discussed already sort of
that the multiple um
strategies uh and policy documents that
are due from government in in the coming
months and they're going to be so vital
for kind of setting out that long-term
trajectory
um and i think i guess the
call from business would be to really
kind of focus on the idea of sector
roadmaps
um because you know we have a number of
of heart decarbonized sectors that we
need to think about you know we
discussed transport
and keith mentioned heavy industry and
you know how we can
develop our long-term kind of
manufacturing and an industrial policy i
think is
is really critical there and it's those
cycles investment cycles in particular
where we need those
um those really long-term signals uh
from
uh from a policy perspective and a
regulatory perspective and
key to all this is that it you know it's
joined up across government i think
in recent advice from the committee on
climate change
um we saw kind of a list of of requests
to different government departments and
it really kind of shows how
uh cross-government to challenge this is
and it really needs to be linked up sort
of
from from the top and it's you know
great sort of see that the prime
minister you know
speaking you know um last week to to the
un's and with his vision
and i think we just we really need to
build on that and have that kind of
really kind of
sort of central idea of how we're going
to knit all this together
uh baroness brown the the the view in
westminster seems to be that
hitting the aim of decarbonizing the
electricity grid by 2030 it is quite
doable
but it's that that last stage
particularly about homes and heating
but it's going to be the most difficult
thing for the uk to manage to achieve
you know replacing every boiler in the
land and the like
what do you think the best answer is
that uh i think
i think you're absolutely right i mean
they the electricity system is the
relatively easy bit
but we shouldn't forget that actually by
uh
by 2050 if we're going to as keith has
said
um use so much more electricity because
of so many
areas of life we're going to electrify
we not only have to decarbonize it
but we probably have to somewhere
between double
and treble it in size so the speed
and scale of growing the new low carbon
electricity system
is also challenging and something we
need to be driving forward
now but as you say decarbonizing our
homes
is probably one of the most challenging
areas
partly because there is um such a
diversity of ownership of our homes a
large proportion of rented homes
a large proportion of owner occupiers a
large proportion of
owner occupiers who have already um paid
for their homes
so all the people who no longer have a
mortgage so you can't necessarily tempt
them by
a very low potentially a very low green
addition to their mortgage
to make the changes that are needed so
we really do i think have to segment
our support to thinking about um uh you
know
thinking about the rented sector can we
do that with levers that say landlords
need
you know can only rent out properties
that are at a given level of uh
of efficiency or at a later date um if
they have
zero carbon heating um you know we we
may be
um council homes are probably um a
rather easier sector
but then we've got to think about how do
we incentivize the owner occupier
and as quasi has said actually um the
new um
green home energy grant scheme that's
just just about to be launched this week
isn't it quasi
um i think is is a pretty good incentive
that will start to move the owner
occupier
um the owner occupier um group and we we
really do need to see
how that progresses and how we can
accelerate that
i i and and one more question about that
what what is your sense
on carbon capture and storage this seems
to be a thing that divides a lot of
opinions some people say oh
it's not really green if it requires
carbon capture and storage other people
argue
that there's no way you're going to get
to net zero by 2050 without carbon
capture and storage
um i think carbon capture and storage is
going to be essential i think um
you know it may even give us the
opportunity to provide negative
co2 emissions by using bioenergy with
carbon capture and storage
uh i hope we won't do more of it
than is absolutely necessary because in
some ways it is storing a problem
for future generations you know just as
storing nuclear waste is some to some
extent
leaving an issue for future generations
but we are going to need to do it so
it's an extent
an essential technology for us to get on
and develop
thank you um keith if i may what do you
think the consumer
appetite for um the greenery is do you
notice your customers are choosing to
pick
uh renewable tariffs you know are they
are they making those are they making
decisions on switching on which
particular tariff to choose
based on how green it is i think
i think consumer engagements get getting
better and better all the time
um you know you know there are a couple
of things in and around the market that
you can look at to say that i mean if
you look at the level of engagement
you know in the in the climate forums
that were created
uh recently you know and people were
really really keen to get involved
and to dedicate a lot of time to it and
that shows you there's a big appetite to
be involved in this and think about it
you know i quote you nice simple
examples like we've got
you know i can look at my window here
and we've got a huge big wind farm now
scott's at glasgow and we get a hundred
thousand people a year coming to visit a
wind farm
i mean that's kind of slightly bonkers
yeah but it shows you
people want to be involved in this they
want to understand that
they want to be a part of it so i think
generally there's
good public engagement you know and it's
been increasingly
increasing increasing all the time but
we need to said earlier what we need to
do is we need to get to the point where
people think it's an easy choice as well
you know we can't force them into this
and if we make this difficult then it
will put people off so
we need to get the costs right we need
to get the investment right we need to
get the choices right
the the heating conversation and and you
know the points well maybe julia
i don't disagree with any of them but
there's another one where
you know to kick-start the market why
don't we start with new build
okay and you know and therefore any new
build home as always date
your hat has to be getting built with
renewable heat
okay and you start the market and you
grow the market you incentivize
companies to invest in the technology
you start to drive down the cost of the
technology you can then look at retrofit
and you need to remember
every year and this every year in this
country there are thousands of boilers
replaced
year on year you know whether it's 10
years old or 15 years old we go through
a boiler replacement program
so it's not as if we have to force bits
of the market
we can do it there are there are
difficult bits of the market that are
hard to reach bits of the market there
are challenges in the market
around buy to let etc but we don't need
all the answers immediately to start
so we need to start now and start with
the easy bits and
start to create the market and start to
create the investment and start to
create the technology wave
because that's what will drive down the
cost and then that will
help us find the answers to the more
difficult solutions and the more
difficult bits of the market
that's the same with technology whether
it's carbon capture and storage
or hydrogen start now and we'll start
working out the answers and we'll find
the answers and then we'll deliver the
technology in the future
and we need to just keep doing it the
concern i always have
is if we focus on the problems we'll
just never do anything
so find the easy bits to start
you're on mute names
um quasi how about it how about only all
new builds have to have hydrogen ready
boilers in them
i think we're we've done a lot actually
in improving the standards
of uh new build housing and actually in
the people i speak to in the sector
and obviously this is a an mhclg a local
government
department issue as well um our the
house builders are very interested
actually much more so than they have
been recently
in uh coming up with new measures which
will be
much more net zero friendly which will
be much more decarbonization friendly
than was the case three years ago i mean
i've mentioned um hydrogen boilers
in conversations this is something that
we're going to be looking at and we've
already
brought or introduced legislation which
will uh
increase the energy efficiency of these
houses starting from 2025 because
obviously
there's a lag in terms of when you start
building these houses so there's a lot
of um policy and that's
um that's being developed the hydrogen
question is still something that we need
to address
partly because at the moment we do not
produce
um cheap hydrogen but surely in the
future when we do
we can actually legislate for houses
that that have to have will require
potentially
uh hydrogen boilers uh
james you worked on um hinckley point c
in the past
is your sense that nuclear is gonna
have to be part of any strategy to get
to net zero by 2050.
yeah i mean you know we've got a large
proportion of our
electricity supplies already coming from
from from nuclear
generation and a lot of those stations
are going to be going offline
during this decade so we really need to
get a plan to
to replace those and as um manus brown
mentioned earlier
to get to net zero we're going to need
to double triple our
electricity capacity uh you know to make
to make it happen and
you know i think nuclear has some real
really sort of strong benefits
particularly as we know that that sort
of ability to you know give predictable
base load
low carbon power and that's you know
help contribute to the the big drops in
um
carbon intensity of of our of our
electricity system in in
in the recent few years and i think it's
hard to see
uh analysis where we don't have new
nuclear in the mix that doesn't
sort of create additional problems
particularly sort of the it would i
think create an additional reliance on
ccos and we know we're going to need a
lot of that anyway
and then it comes back to this point
that we need all the technologies
at hand because they're all going to
play it play a part whether that be
nuclear or ccos you know
for power and industry but you know
hydrogen for example in
a range of areas so i think that nucleus
remains sort of really key
you know that there's great progress at
hinkley point c um currently in terms of
construction you know things that you
know are
are sticking to time uh you know people
were sort of you know have been critical
of nuclear projects and in in the past
in other places sort of over running and
i think a lot of lessons have been
learned and they're being put
into best practice at hinckley and
clearly there's now a need to kind of to
replicate that
um because you know it's i think it's
it's no use of just doing a standalone
project because then you don't kind of
build on those those sort of
learnings both in terms of cost
reduction but also industrial
capabilities as well you know the 25 000
construction jobs
uh involved with a project like that and
again thinking around the priorities of
a green recovery if we
can develop our nuclear capacity both
sort of largely on nuclear but also
small modular reactors which sort of
feels like another
great option for our power sector again
the kind of the from the industrial
perspective
uh both from from our skills side but
also from an export side as well looking
forward so i think i think nuclear has
to be a part of the solution
uh keith you are a cop 26 business
leader what do you think would be a
realistic aim in terms of international
commitments at that summit in glasgow
next year
do you think we could get kind of
countries all around the world agree to
phase out coal for example
i'll do yeah i yeah i think to me the
trick with
the trick with cop 26 is
actually try and shift some of the focus
away from from
just being about international
agreements and actually trying to shift
some of the focus away to being about
success stories and and talking about
success stories
and you know and the conversation should
be about here's the benefits of doing
this and doing it well
so i i you know i i think the uk has got
a fantastic story
uh as harvard you're a number of other
countries about
you know don't don't go into this
thinking tackling climate change is a
big horrible messy expensive
dreadful issue actually go into this
understanding if you do this properly if
you attack it in the right way
if you put in the right processes and
mechanisms actually tackling
climate change not only is it beneficial
from an environmental point of view
economically it brings a huge boost to
the country
and that that to me is where we will get
the greatest gain
internationally not not just so much and
can we all agree to face call out by
this day or that day
to me the biggest gain and the biggest
push we should keep making
is showing people economically here's
what tackling climate change can bring
in terms of benefits in terms of jobs
manufacturing traineeships economic
growth
uh infrastructure um you know building
an economy
building new businesses your new digital
technologies
you get huge economic benefit from doing
this and doing well if you look at all
the stuff that's happened around
offshore wind
and all of the investment that's coming
in the back of it and i think
that's a a much more positive way to go
and approach this than just
focusing i mean i know that targets are
targets are important and international
agreements are important but the more we
can do this and promote and show the
idea about
here's the benefit of doing this not
just from an environmental point of view
but from an economic point of view to me
that will drive greater success than
just
doing it around trying to get targets
rns king do you think that's the right
approach to cop26
i certainly think that's uh that's a
very important part of it i think
showing success stories is an enormously
motivating way of getting people to
think they want to do that
and and i do also think the fact that
global renewable energy spending is set
to surpass
oil and gas in 2021 some of the modeling
that cameron hepburn and the team at
oxford have done you know showing that
that we could get to this tipping point
in investment
when the majority of investment is in
renewables rather than fossil fuels
and suddenly investing in fossil fuels
starts to feel a very insecure thing to
do
and then we start really to accelerate
that transition
and i think kind of demonstrating that
kind of thing so
you know actually in a way sort of
almost undermining the confidence of
investing in
in fossil fuels and getting that tipping
point in the investment system
to come earlier is is really key quasi
how would you define success for cop 26
um i think targets
are important i mean i took on board one
keith said and i agree with him
but you know the whole nature of the
international engagement is that we have
these nationally defined contributions
and you know those
inevitably involve target so we're going
to have to agree
i think uh to a set of targets
uh that we are committed to as an
international as international players
and part of the
international community having said that
i think what baroness brown said about
the investing
uh investment climate is really really
important
um because i think actually uh
ultimately
if the private sector private capital
isn't signed up to this
we're not going to get anywhere near our
targets and the kind of
i think the technical term in finance or
financial analysts use is de-rating
so that means that the multiple at which
these um fossil fuel companies trade
is going lower and lower because they're
seen as being
less secure investments and i think that
uh baroness brown
uh has done very well actually to raise
that because that's a huge part
of this of this picture but in terms of
cop26 specifically that i think there
will be targets and there will be
um ambitious nationally uh national
defined contributions
we're now going to move to your
questions thank you very much sending
them in keep them coming
uh the first question comes from chris
and i'm going to start with you james
uh [ __ ] says what does government and
business plan to do to bring rural
awkward users along on this journey
i think we've picked up on on one of the
challenges around
the development of our grid networks and
ensuring that the
you know electricity supply system um
uh can deliver properly and again that
comes back to the point around the need
for sort of long-term investment
and you know the the business government
and uh
engagement with off gem as well and
keith mentioned the the recent sort of a
draft
termination on on rio 2 which is
obviously a a point
around sort of what how much can be
invested by by network companies so we
need to get that balance right so we get
that anticipatory investment and that's
going to be key both for you know
electrification of heat and people's
home
has been also you know the need for for
charging infrastructure for
for electric vehicles um but you know i
think we know
we do need that kind of you know always
a uk-wide kind of
thought process when we when we when we
can tackle these issues
um you know it's easy to be kind of
urban centric and that's where
a lot of our kind of problems are in
terms of i guess the numbers of people
but you know no one can be left behind
you know it needs to be
a just and fair transition and that
needs to be both in terms of people's
jobs but also the cost
of of doing things so i think you know
from a both from a transport perspective
um and not not forgetting to the role of
public transport in
in rural areas as well and ensuring that
that's really up to scratch because i
think you know we all recognize that
that's sort of been a an area where you
know we you know we
we've lost out on investment so you know
that that's another area where i think
we can bring in the
the whole leveling up agenda to ensure
that the rural communities you know are
left behind in the transition
uh quasi what how what do you think the
government can do to make sure that
this transition kind of works for
everyone well
i think james made the point uh just now
i think that
the leveling up agenda funnily enough um
dovetails very nicely
in with the decarbonization agenda
because if we look at where our
old uh and new actually industrial
clusters are
if we see where the industrial carbon
emissions are very many of them i mean
i'm thinking of
uh humber i'm thinking t side i'm
thinking of
uh the mersey area many of these
um high uh carbon intensive
uh industrial hubs um were the site
of um great amounts of industry over the
last hundred years
but they are also uh attracting
investment
for new technologies we've talked about
offshore wind
alstead are based um just off uh the
humber
in the north sea there i see it empire
which is better
electrolyzer for green manufacturing
green hydrogen
that's based in sheffield we've got the
t side um
development council the south tees
development council which is very
focused on clean energy and
renewable energy and new technologies so
um it's just by accident really
that uh many of the areas where we need
to quote
unquote level up are precisely the areas
where
um deployment of capital and investment
in new technologies
um can can best be made
yeah uh our next question which i'd like
to start with you
baroness brown on is is 2050 quick
enough um
uh question from someone saying that
this needs to be done even faster than
that do you do you think 2050
is the first realistic date for this
i think we would all love to do this
faster but when you look at the
when you look at the scale of the
challenge we've got to between double
and treble the size of the electricity
industry
we've got to start a hydrogen industry
almost from scratch
and grow it to the size the electricity
industry is today
we've got to um we've got to
move from having you know what is it a
few hundred thousand
electric vehicles to having something
like 30 million electric vehicles we've
got
30 million buildings which need to be
converted
to low carbon heat we've got to uh we've
got to make space for
planting you know 30 000 to
50 000 hectares of trees which means
changing our farming practices
and indeed changing you know the way
some of our farmers will earn their
livelihoods
these are huge changes and i think we've
got to be realistic
about um we're going to have to go very
fast
to get that done by 2050. i think that's
doable
i'd love it to be earlier but i think we
do have to be realistic about the scale
of change we've got to make
keith um what's your perspective in the
perspective of industry do you mean is
you have a baroness brown said that you
know however nice it might be to be able
to aim to be aiming for 2045 or 2040
is 2050 really the most realistic time
frame
yeah i think god i don't think we should
worry too much about
the you're the day and should we shift
the day should we move the day okay
we've got a date
we've got in legislation the uk you know
is taking a bold step and doing it and
it's a fantastic thing to do
uh the fact is net zero is incredibly
important because it avoids any jability
around what
we're trying to achieve so i i i'm not
that bothered about it
what i would say to you is if we if we
create the right frameworks the right
mechanisms
the right incentives are the right
marketplaces
we'll smash the target out of the water
okay and
you know we've got plenty of good good
examples of having done that you mean
that do you mean by that we'll get there
quicker well i think if you're as you
look at each of the segments and
you know if you if you look at what's
been done with offshore wind
you know um you know five five ten years
ago we kind of dreamt
that we were trying to offshore when
below 100 100 pounds by 2020
we're sitting here in 2020 and projects
are burning in at 35 pounds
we've annihilated the target because
we've got the market right
we've got the investment right we've got
the innovation right
and we've got the structure of the
process and the framework correct
you look at what's going on with the evs
just now where 2040 and people were
going oh my god 20 40
it's difficult and now everybody's
talking about 20 35 20 30.
again you know the market if you get the
market set right you get the investment
right
we'll start banging these things out and
then you'll we'll get there
if we can do the same with heat then
it's fantastic okay
don't change the target don't move the
target if we spend our life talking
about whether the answer is 2050 or 2045
we'll miss the entire point of it and
leave the target out there leave the
date out there
and now let's just focus on the
mechanisms that deliver against it and
how we get there
and if you you know what we've shown
time and time again in this country
you know this is like a credit to the
government and then previous governments
you know we're brilliant at inventing
the right balance of regulatory
and market process we're great at
bringing together
some really really good frameworks that
incentivize investment and innovation
if we keep doing that we'll do it we'll
deliver
brilliant thank you keith james um when
you look around the world
um are there other countries in time
that we should be learning from in terms
of policies in this area
i mean you know the uk i think actually
been a bit of a a leader in ourselves
particularly from the
the policy perspective uh you know the
frameworks have been
put in place so you know keith was just
describing that have delivered such you
know
you know at the time sort of you know
unbelievable forcing costs i think those
are things that
other countries you know are learning uh
about from us
um so i think there's a lot that we can
be proud of
um and again i think this the moment
that we're at now um as a lot of other
countries are now thinking about you
know how they can use a green recovery
to also sort of
uh you know move forward from the
pandemic there's the moment when you
know we need to look at this
uh you know we can't lose out on our
international leadership here so we need
to kind of
keep that that pace of innovation in
terms of our policy ideas and you know
um the you know the call then to
government to
keep being bold around its decision
making um
making decisions that are also sort of
timely and again so through the
strategies that we've heard about
um that that needs to happen so that we
can keep pace you know we've seen some
um you know large-scale um investment
announcements from
you know the french and german
governments in hydrogen particularly
which has sort of been well documented
so those are examples of how sort of i
guess the competition is trying to sort
of
um sort of catch up or overtake but i
think you know from a policy perspective
you know we've got a lot to
um to be proud of but you know but you
know there are some
some areas that where we can learn i
think you know i think you know looking
at low carbohydrate for example
other countries that sort of have a
similar kind of profiles to us like the
netherlands for example to also have a
strong reliance on natural gas i think
they've made more progress when it comes
to
um sort of decarbonizing their heat
system so they're so that's just one
example of i guess
we know we can can look abroad to get
some uh insights but you know we should
be proud of what we've done and sort of
the uh you know the innovative thinking
that we've done from a policy
perspective here
thank you james quizzy i think emmanuel
macron's talked about spending kind of
four percent of french gdp on green
measures
angela merkel talked about i think about
six percent of german gdp
um do you think we need that kind of
cash investment
to to maintain our current position
internationally in this area
i mean i hate to be nitpicking but the
announcements they made
were part of a general economic recovery
yes they put the green
bit if you like at the center of that
but the four percent of gdp the two
percent of gdp you're talking about
130 billion euros um
you know we've committed to spending i
think at least as much as that if not
more
um across the economy and we've also
said
very specifically that the green
recovery will be at the center of that
so
while not all the spending is
necessarily focused
uh on the green recovery the green
recovery is
at the center and the most important
element uh in terms of the spending
uh baroness brown you used to be on on
the um
the one of the non-executive directors
of the green investment bank
do you think that the uk needs another
iteration of that
to kind of further push forward uh this
agenda
yes i'm i'm a big fan of that as a as a
mechanism
i think the the green investment bank
did a brilliant job
um in the offshore wind area of moving
offshore wind from being
seen as a high risk investment to being
seen as
as a investment that every pension fund
wanted to have part of that it was
you know you could be really confident
in it and and it moved not only
the operating wind farms to being an
investment that people could be
confident in
it actually moved um development of wind
farms
to being an investment people could be
confident in which of course brought
down the cost of investment
which was a big chunk in the early days
of the reduction in costs in the costs
of
offshore wind i mean clearly they've
been huge technology developments and
much much bigger turbines
that have been part of that story as
well but the cost of money was also a
big chunk and i think the green
investment bank
did a really good job of of
demonstrating that the government
because it was putting
it was it was putting government's money
alongside other
drawing in other investments money of
saying the government genuinely believes
in this
and he's going to stick with it it is
the long-term policy
this is something uh that you can that
you can
put your money into and de-risked it
that way and i think there are so many
other areas like hydrogen like carbon
capture and storage
um where's an approach and some of the
other technologies we're going to need
where an approach like that i think
would be very helpful um and i know
discussions have been going on and i um
lord stern has been
lobbying and i've heard quasi mention
these things so
i'm i'm hoping that uh that we might be
seeing something like that coming
forward
uh keith for an industry perspective is
that something you would welcome
yeah absolutely you know look i you know
i think
everything to me is going in the right
direction and i think we've got
great stuff going on in the country a
great focus on this in the country
uh great policies in the country a huge
willingness to invest
uh in the future of this and you know
it's it's
and we just need to you know just to
trigger the right actions now and get
everything shifting and everything
moving in the right direction and i
think yeah
um yeah i think we're in a good place
and we've got a huge opportunity
uh ahead of us and i think this is and
you know i think we should be really
positive
and um we come with running up towards
the end of our hour i thought what i
might just do
is ask everyone to give me to give us
i don't even got time for more than a
minute or so of closing thoughts
on the best way to do it so i'll reverse
the order from earlier so james do you
want to give your minute on
what you think would most help business
and industry
get to this net zero target by 2050
yeah i think for me it's pretty clear
that between now and cop 26
we want to get a really sort of strong
set
of uh policy road maps in place and to
kind of really kind of map out the
trajectory for
uh for different sectors and
particularly um
next steps for the for the energy market
in the ng white paper we've mentioned
the decomposition of transport plan our
heating buildings
um i i'm really going to set that out
clearly so you know the businesses sort
of know
kind of the context they're going to be
operating in but you know let's not be
held back by
creating sort of the perfect framework
at this sense you know we
need we can keep options open they don't
need to be sort of final decisions but
you know just to get things moving and i
think you know
now is such a brilliant opportunity to
do that and buy cop26 if we've done it
then
that's going to be one of the elements
of success and it's going to help us
sort of get lots of other countries
sort of matching our ambition level
quasi what
what are your final yeah i mean look i
think uh what uh
both um julia and keith anderson said
just now um really captures what we're
trying to do i think
uh with regards to the green investment
bank i think he did a great job
in its time of uh wedding together
uh private and public uh capital that's
the only way we're gonna get
to where we need to get to is a
combination of both
the private sector can't do it on its
own and the
and the public sector can't do it on its
own
um the other thing that i would suggest
is that um
in line with uh what james has just said
um i think that the policy framework is
pretty robust i think we have shown some
leadership there's clearly a long way to
go
uh and there are difficult hard to abate
sectors like
uh how homes have built things we
mentioned one or two of them today
but i think the broad direction as keith
said is is in a good place and i just
hope we can
renew our energy and increase our
efforts but we're certainly going in the
right direction on this
uh keep what are your final closing
thoughts for us i just think
we should go into this now with uh with
the mindset that there are
there are really very few regrets in
anything we
do so you know if we accelerate
investment if we advance investment if
we do stuff quickly if we shift quickly
if we use
existing technology there's very little
in any of that that we could regret
so i think there are very few risks
around stranded assets or
lost investment or missed opportunity so
we can move quickly
we can do stuff quickly um there's so
much to do
uh the faster we move the better so we
just get
uh yo we're historically shown it we get
the best mix between regulatory
frameworks
market frameworks government and
government incentive and
and government input as well and you
know we we can go quickly and we can
move quickly and we just
we just need to start moving now
thank you baroness brown the last word
to you i well i agree with
all the things that have been said um i
i'd also like to say
that i think um as keith has said we've
got all the technologies that we need
for the next 10 to 15 years of of rapid
progress
but i i do hope despite the the
challenging financial situation we're in
that that we will still be able to
really invest and up our investment in
science and innovation
because we do still need those new
innovations
for the last 10 years and the world
doesn't end at 2050
the challenges go on beyond so i think
alongside all of this
we need that that up of upping of our
our ambition
in the science and innovation area to
help us be real leaders
for the future well i think with this
downstream you won't have any difficulty
in getting more funding for
science and all research is left to do
is me to bank the panel forever an
absolutely
fascinating and fantastic discussion i
think so often when you host these
these fringe events at party conference
you come away from the
discussion meeting rather downbeat
because it's about some problem that we
don't appear to have any uh ability to
solve but i thought today was very
different and a very positive discussion
about something where we where this
country seems to be making real progress
and and and has a great claim to be a
global leader so
really all it's left for me to do i'd
normally ask the audience to clap but
seeing as they're all sitting at home
they're probably all on mute um but all
i can do is say thank you all so much
for
uh your thoughts today thank you all at
home for tuning in
and uh there is an event with joe
johnson later on this afternoon on
universities
uh and then an event uh uh later on this
evening
about the magic money tree and how much
the government can keep spending but
thank you to my panel today absolutely
excellent discussion and thank you for
tuning in